pourquoi la démocratie moderne benfeld à
représenter le peuple
ça c'est la grosse question le problème
je crois c'est que la notion même de
représentation du poc est une notion au
fond compliqué contradictoires quoi
parce que ça tu poses toujours que il ya
le pop qui existe comme une grande
réalité collecte comme ça plus ou moins
identifiés à la population secteurs de
la population et piguet on se pose la
question de savoir comment on va le
représenter
mais je veux dire que une population en
tant que telle c'est pas un peu
politique peuple politique c'est pas
simplement en visons une masse de gens
un peuple politique c'est l'objet d'une
sorte de construction peut dire une
construction institutionnelle une
construction symbolique qui fait que en
réalité un peuple c'est toujours un
résultat conséquent je dirais qu'on est
toujours avec ce problème que on fait
comme si démocratie ça voulait dire que
le peuple comme totalité ils ont des
gens qui vivent sur un territoire
étaient représentés mais non c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué que ça en
réalité des représentations veut dire
précisément l'absence de ports ou doudou
dis que finalement on crée un peuple
d'un certain type donc il n'ya pas le
peuple et puis la représentation il ya
au fond des institutions dé manière de
faire qui crée un certain type de
peuples donc voilà nos régimes moderne
créé un certain type de peuples qui en
gros bond à la fois exposé souverain et
disons dont la souveraineté consiste
essentiellement tous les cinq ans à fond
ils ont acquiescé à la manière dont la
classe politicienne gérer chose donc
effectivement bon sac reda mélancolie ou
sacrés de la frustration
[Musique]